this video is going to be a rant there
is not really a script and I have not
really thought this through but I would
like to talk about some things that are
on my mind and that I don't see
discussed very often with respect to
coronavirus I'm not a medical expert I
don't play a doctor on the internet and
there absolutely is no need to follow
any of my advice or take anything as
advice that I say I just want to talk
and maybe someone else will have a good
idea of what I talk so it is a crazy
world we live in I would have never
thought at the beginning of this year
that this would be the year where
everyone stays at their house and works
from home and I've always thought that
in a time like this when the economy is
going down basically the thing of value
would be something like Bitcoin or
really theorem or alternative things but
no everything's going down and the
actual new currency of choice is toilet
paper
everyone's gonna grab the toilet paper
what a crazy world where the most
trusted news source is someone like
Tucker Carlson yeah didn't see that one
coming thanks Tucker for saving us so I
don't know what to make of this and I do
know that this is a serious situation
and you should definitely do everything
you can to take care of yourself and to
take care of your community what I want
to talk about is the question of what is
it going to do long term so if we think
about this we often think about this
right now we have an exponential
increase in number of cases you've
probably seen this and you've probably
seen graphics like these where the goal
is to fly
and the curve the sense behind this
being that if this Rises exponentially
of course at some point it will affect
the entire population so it's going to
flatten out and if you look at the
number of new cases daily it might be
some curve like this the problem is that
we only have a finite capacity of
healthcare systems so all these people
are basically going to be screwed
once we get to this point now the goal
is to flatten the curve that we can take
some measures to keep this curve under
at the capacity of our healthcare system
these measures are varying wildly so it
is these measures that I want to talk
about a bit
now these measures range from something
like social distancing right where you
basically say all right no big events
no no groups of large people social
distancing and you know just kind of
kind of a avoid contact with other
people now of course all the CES
departments of the world go like well
this is business as usual like yay we've
practiced for this our entire lives so
it is mildly inconvenient but you know
we can keep it up
all the way to lockdown lockdown comes
also in various forms but the most
drastic sense is stay home or you'll get
shot or locked up or something like this
and this is this discrepancy of course
the more down on the curve you go the
more you're going to theoretically
flatten this out the more the less you
do the higher your peak is going to be
but it's not that easy I find if you
look at the cases here of course your
exponential your rising but if you look
at where the outbreak started in China
the orange curve here you actually see
the number of cases flattening out
now you see it flattening out at
something like a hundred K and last I
know China has more people than 100 K so
that means not everyone's infected now
with a disease that infects this easily
spreads this easily from person to
person as it appears to be the case
there are two possibilities either the
rest of China which china is over a
billion people and this is 100 K so the
entire rest of China basically almost
all of China is asymptomatic which the
latest numbers are here are that maybe
50% of cases are asymptomatic or the
other possibility is that most of China
has yet to be infected now with a virus
like this if you look at the
distribution it's basically arrived
everywhere in the world so there is very
very little hope of snuffing this thing
out actually making it stop which what
you'd have to do is you'd have to lock
every single person down for two to
three weeks and now only a single person
that doesn't keep - that can start a new
outbreak so what I fully expect to
happen if these numbers are correct and
if China actually has done this
successfully
so flattens this curve successfully is
that let's say the green thing here is
China is that okay they get to a point
where they feel they have no new cases
for a while so they let the restriction
up right they remove the restriction
there's going to be some person
somewhere in some Z s Department that
now goes outside and meets another
person and in that particular person
here the virus happens to have an
incubation period of 21 days instead of
14 and they're going to transmit that to
2 3 4 5 people after these measures
everyone's going to be longing for
social contacts and large groups and we
might gradually loosen the restrictions
but still a new outbreak is inevitable
it seems
so what you'll have again is a spike and
then a country might enact measures
again and so on but I believe the world
we're going to live in if we really lock
down people if we really enforce these
measures is a world of multiple repeated
seasonal peaks of this disease and that
means we are in for the long term I
don't I don't want to say ever that we
shouldn't do that because it of course
effectively reduces the number of deaths
which should be our ultimate goal here
but just know that flattening the curve
wants like these graphics here is a bit
misleading I believe we need to be
thinking about a long term plan here and
since we're going long term and with
long term
I mean months I mean multiple years and
with long term the problem here is the
people and I want to elaborate on that
so the the largest problem are the
people people aren't just machines that
you can command around people are
individuals they have their own ideas
they have their own goals that they want
to fulfill right at some point I'm gonna
go on a vacation this is an island with
a tree so let's talk about lockdown
lockdown it appears to be a thing that
is necessary in some parts if you ask
some people again I don't want to give
advice on this I just want to give some
thoughts so what you get with lockdown
with lockdown you get oMG it's happening
and so that's day 1 day 3 you get funny
YouTube videos everyone that is in
lockdown will do be like oh I'm stuck at
home it's so boring
already forgetting that other people
have major issues with being locked down
a lot of people sitting on top of each
other is going to create a lot of
problems and eventually more and more
people are going to long for this to end
and I'm not saying that you know that is
that a response to a virus should be fun
but what I'm saying is that people are
going to break this it is inevitable
first some are going to break then more
you have a very delicate balance going
on here right now there is a lot of
support a lot of people are on the side
of locking things down in a lockdown a
lot of people are conscientious staying
home avoiding social contact as much as
possible but some are going to be the
first ones to go over there some are
going to break some are going to find
excuses not to keep to it and the
problem is the harder the measures are
the harder you are down here the
stronger the poll is going to be for
people to go on this other side and I
guarantee you the people on social media
that are shaming others the most that
are yelling out the loudest for others
to not break the lockdown either they
have an extremely comfortable living at
their own homes which is an extreme
privilege or they are the worst ones to
break it to themselves to find every
excuse they can why they are exempt from
it and people are going to see this more
and more people are going to be over
here and with more people over here look
they have the sunshine they're out and
about they're doing their things more
like normal the people over here they're
going to see this and more and more
people will be hey why am i keeping to
this why am I not over there why can't
these people do that and they'll go and
at some point the scale is going to tip
and any lockdown
barring martial law and the threat of
being shot if you go outside will be
ineffective and at that point wherever
you are the cases are going to spy
and it'll be even worse than when you
did nothing or as bad so I believe that
is very delicate balance that you have
to strike here total lockdown people
aren't going to take this for a long
time and you need to think about a long
time here I don't know what the answer
is I don't know where exactly the scale
of just keep part to stay home whatever
it takes
yes I just think that too harsh measures
can also be counterproductive I'm very
fortunate to live in Switzerland most of
our neighbors have instituted total lock
downs and the Swiss government has
recently decided not to do so at this
time with I believe much of the same
reasoning as I'm just laying out we need
to think about this long term and people
are not going to keep to a lockdown long
term and it'll be worse if they don't
now I believe the best response to
something like this is a distributed one
I believe the best response is to go to
people in their networks people usually
care about the people around them enough
so that they will take responsibility
into the hand I believe you should in I
believe you should give the people the
responsibility as much responsibility as
you can and I believe the network of
people each one arranging themselves in
the most pro-social way can be the best
response better than any government
could do governments can do things such
as prohibit large gatherings you know
sometimes if you don't do that
even the individual people can do
anything against that but to actually
believe in your citizens and believe in
the fundamental goodness of humans and
the fundamental care for other humans is
a strong suit here on the other hand you
see other governments I have read that a
city in Norway is
thinking about employing a monitoring
systems where they track everyone's
phone and if more than a certain amount
of people are in the same place they
will basically send everyone a text
message saying you should disperse while
this is an effective measure and I
believe can definitely help and it is
something that you need to be very
careful about as we saw with 911 as soon
as governments get power they rarely let
it go as well Edward Snowden finally
demonstrated if you enact something like
this you must definitely make sure that
there is a time limit on it any
government measure right now be that
spending to help the economy which is
certainly a good thing be this measures
to increase social distancing to
prohibit public gatherings I support
this but it must be time limited
otherwise governments aren't gonna let
this go finally I would like to come to
a more global scale of long term
thinking countries and other countries
as you go on you need to think about
your economy our economies were growing
a fairly good pace until this hit and
now they're plunging at any point
they're going to be opportunists they're
going to be personal opportunists
hoarding toilet paper and hand sanitizer
and trying to sell them for market up
prices and they're going to be country
opportunists everything's falling down
if you're the country that locks things
down now your economy is going to fall
eventually though you'll have to get
back the countries that get back sooner
will be in an upswing sooner basically
the question is where is the ideal point
here to leave the to not react anymore
to let people do their thing to get back
on track I don't know where that is but
I believe you're going to see
cold war like situation in the world
where countries are going in key accuse
other countries of not doing enough or
doing too much of not playing fairly of
helping to spread the virus and I
believe that it will be the case for the
years to come because what happens over
the long time of course right now you
can afford to not fix that pipe under
your house that's broken you can afford
to not clean the do not get the person
to clean the chimney you can afford to
not get dental work done I don't even
know how to draw tooth let's say this is
a tooth probably has some peaks here
over the long term though all of these
things are going to break and we need to
get back to normal and the longer estate
keeps up these measures the worse it's
going to get finally we need to talk
about risk people people at risk tend to
be older tend to be ones with health
issues think about this if you're an old
person having health issues you're
looking at a long term once you realize
this is not going to be over in a few
weeks what do you do year old and the
next year or so in lockdown mode it's
going to be hard for you and for
everyone but a year if you're that old
and sick is probably more quality life
you have left then after it so you need
to be thinking either I'm going to
survive this because I bunker in my
house don't get the virus but what is it
worth because my other diseases will get
me afterwards otherwise I could be
spending the quality time I have with my
family with my children with my
grandchildren could be spending it with
my friends and if I die I die it is not
an easy question but I'm
absolutely sure there are people right
now who are asking themselves this if
you're a government in your thinking
about mandatory lockdown I I do see that
this is in order to save people in order
to not have people walking around that
spread the virus to vulnerable
populations but you need to be thinking
about the people you're trying to help
some of them would actually be on this
side I don't know what the best response
is to everything here I think we're just
going to see and I don't want to give
advice this is just some of the things I
think I wish everyone the absolute
healthiest season they can have right
now take care please think about others
please do not make the problem worse
yourself you're a part of a network and
you can be a powerful force for good
during this time think about long term
if you're asking your government to do
things think about what's the best
situation and how we're gonna get there
thanks and stay healthy